this is let us all the first image I
said no wow like you read about them in
our scientific life we're looking this
the mystery of nature that has never
uncovered your answer so this is it with
finally seen it scientists came up with
this crazy idea in the 1930s and they
never imagined that one day we would
actually see a black hole it's so far
only a few blurry splotches of light and
yet they contain so much information
about the physics of the universe I've
been dreaming about this for 25 years
when I fought saw the first data it was
just some weird plot it looked like
there could be a ring in there I was
like oh my god this is gonna be
interesting
it looks pretty much what we were
expecting which was for a theoretician
is always an you know a dramatic moment
when you have to compare what you spent
years simulating with what actually
nature is telling you this is just like
kind of the beginning of being able to
have another window into what black
holes can tell us about our laws and in
physics but already we've learned so
much so you know we didn't know even
though we had predicted that if you had
a black hole that you would see this
ring of light we didn't know we were
gonna get that ring away and that's you
know what we were kind of testing we
could have gone in just a blob and so
seeing that ring and seeing a ring that
has a size that is consistent with other
measurements that can hadn't been done
completely differently I think that in
itself just being able to see that ring
of life being able to see that that ring
exists is huge we are also releasing
this data that has from the event
horizon telescope that were used to
create this image so whoever out there
has a you know alternative theory of
gravity can just grab this data and test
it well the big goal still is to make an
image of the black hole in the
of our Milky Way because it has a much
better determine mass and so we can do
much better tests of general relativity
and we can also have other telescopes
look at it their infrared
interferometers we can see gas going
around it so combining all these
information will give us a much better
image of how black holes actually work
the picture we have seen today is only a
first taste of what the event horizon
telescope and delivered already the data
they have in the back can produce a lot
more information for example about what
produces the Jets these enormous beams
of light that we see coming out of the
galaxy m87 also the team has collected a
lot of data about another black hole the
one at the center of our own galaxy and
they haven't even started analyzing so
stay tuned there's a lot more to come
you